tras casi un año de detectarse el primer
positivo en el país argentina superó el
viernes los 50 mil muertos por kobe 19
además sus más de 2 millones de
contagios reportados la ubican como el
tercer país más afectado de américa
latina junto al número de muertes
preocupa también el 54,6 de ocupación de
las camas su ciento del país que
asciende al 59 8 en el área
metropolitana de buenos aires junto a
ello la falta de vacunas ha provocado la
demora en el esperado proceso de
vacunación no hay vacuna nos llega la
vacuna no se logra producir lo que hay
que producir pero nosotros tenemos un
problema extra esto que es graves graves
problemas de comunicación hacia nuestra
población una expectativa muy alta
respecto de la vacuna una utilización
con el tema de la vacuna que lo único
que hace simplemente es alejar todavía
más a la gente de la credibilidad en la
vacuna argentina impuso uno de los
confinamientos más estrictos de américa
latina' al inicio de la pandemia
las medidas se relajaron paulatinamente
y las infecciones se incrementaron
después de las vacas
este fin de año ahora el país se prepara
para la vuelta escalonada a las aulas
cerradas desde el inicio de la pandemia
en marzo de 2020 volverá a clase y esta
vez no tiene las características de la
vuelta a clases de un día de marzo
cualquiera de nuestra vida anterior es
distinto
es volver a clase llena de cuidados
con distancia preservando
la distancia y la cercanía entre
docentes y alumnos
priorizando la salud de los docentes que
debemos ayudarlos en su vacunación lo
antes posible fundamentalmente los más
adultos con la llegada de nuevas dosis
de la vacuna sputnik 5 argentina espera
a aire en su proceso de vacunación
pero aún parece lejos el momento en que
se pueda lograr la inmunidad colectiva